[Musique]
tous les gens ma famille qui m'ont vu
sur scène c'est le seul cas pas changé
non
on pourrait croire c'est parce qu il me
soutient mais je crois que c'est juste
qu'il entend plus rien
sur moi il aime tellement lire des
articles que je suis sûr c'est lui qui
lance tout l'est pour les mig
mais quand il les lit pas il ne perd pas
son temps il a même une petite jeune de
75 ans à apa
[Musique]
ah ah
bonne anniversaire ma faim
il a fait la politique tout en temps
c'est comme ça qu'il m'a appris à voler
de l'argent
il dit j'ai vu ton spectacle 50 fois mes
jetons
jour comme la première
comme quoi tu vois ya quand même de bons
côtés
aujourd'hui à avoir alzheimer
et puis si j'en suis là c'est grâce à
lui d'enfants car très tôt il a mis de
la bière dans mon biberon
tapas
on n'est pas de panique
à
[Musique]
papa